now of course there's lots of talk about
emma radacano of course there is she is
the british teen tennis sensation
and she's back in bromley in london
after she starred in her very own fairy
tale in new york that's a cliche which
is getting old already
has to be said when she won the u.s open
just 18 years old not only that but the
first qualifier ever to win a grand slam
and managed to achieve that incredible
feat without losing a single
set well jackie has been talking to her
this morning
yeah it's a really nice feeling to be
home i have been able to spend some time
with my parents after not seeing them
for seven weeks so
we we just had a nice meal together last
night with some homemade dumplings and
uh i've re-watched the final just to
just to relive some experiences
and what was that like were you tense
re-watching the final
yeah i just really wanted to let the
moment sink in and i thought that would
help but um it i knew exactly what it
was going to happen in all of the points
but watching is definitely more
stressful than playing because you feel
like you have control at least when
you're playing when you're watching
um you you have no control and
but it was really cool to just be able
to
relive some of those moments and at the
end i i saw my slide when i fell and uh
it was quite long and i actually
impressed myself with that in slight
motion
it was a very impressive slide when you
saw your mum and dad for the first time
you know what did they say to you
because well played doesn't really cover
it does it
yeah they just gave me a hug there was
nothing really crazy they have very high
standards and uh tough love but i think
that i didn't really need anything big
from them i know that
just the smallest of congratulations
means a lot and for them to say they're
proud of me as well but they they were
very happy to have me home
life-changing experience emma you know
reporters paparazzi outside of your
house you are instantly recognizable
everywhere
are you ready for that how much your
life has now
changed yeah i actually haven't really
realized because i just came home and
i've just been staying at home spending
time with my family so i haven't really
gone out or done anything yet so i don't
really see at the moment any changes
well you've been super busy since that
match point you've done loads of things
at new york you've done chat shows
you've been to the met gala
well you looked fantastic um what was
the highlight of all those things that
you did because you won
thank you i think the highlight
of my time after the final was honestly
that night that of the final i just
spent it with my team in a really nice
intimate room and we just spoke about
the whole three weeks experience and
reflecting upon all the time uh there
was there was like a karaoke bus on the
way back from the courts when we were
singing sweet caroline and mr brightside
and we just had a really nice meal
together and discussed everything and
just chatted the whole time through
yeah and he's still going on adrenaline
because you were there for a very long
time you played 10 matches you've done a
lot of media afterwards you know are you
still on a high or you're starting to
feel a bit tired
yeah i think i'm still on a high when i
got home yesterday i just slept the
whole day so i think it's that i'm just
starting to recover and
rest and i think my body needs it after
the experience that i've had for the
last seven eight weeks andy murray
called obviously congratulated you
massively and he called it a great
opportunity
for british tennis what would it mean to
you if little girls and boys were
picking up a racket because of you
because you are their inspiration
yeah i mean it means a lot to to hear
that i think that
i want to just inspire you know little
girls or young children to to dream big
you know not even if it's not tennis if
it's other dreams like in in school
being a doctor or anything like that um
i just want to inspire them to dream big
and anything can happen but then also
for tennis i think it's
i just want to get across that you can
be a normal kid you can go to school
have all of the normal things and still
achieve
results and um i think that's that's my
main message to to all the kids out
there
it's a very sensible message as well
the liverpool manager jurgen klopp has
called you talent of the century he said
he was inspired by you he's now going to
watch a lot more women's tennis in the
future when you hear things like that
how does it make you feel
yeah i mean it's it's very very nice to
hear and i'm very grateful i think that
women's tennis at the moment is
extremely strong and the depth that the
game has um all of the players can
pretty much win every event and uh i'm
really grateful to mr jurgen klopp for
his comment
do you have a football team
i have i'm my football team is england
i'm not i'm not going into the actual
future
maybe it's maybe it should be liverpool
now um you are a bigger i know you're a
big f1 fan um you've always been a big
formula one fan the drivers have all
been talking about you lewis hamilton
said he was inspired by you and he
admired your focus and determination
um and you've been talking to him i
believe
yeah i mean i love formula one an
awesome and also motorsports i spoke to
lewis hamilton at the met gala and it
was really cool just to just to speak to
him and
after everything he's achieved he's such
a great inspiration
but in in formula one i mean i love
watching all the brits um you know lando
and uh georgia as well they they're all
they're all really cool to be flying
flying the flag high for for great
britain
and
he called it also
a dream it proves that dreams can come
true um does it still feel like a dream
has it properly sunk in yet what you've
achieved
gradually i think as time's passing you
you realize but it's funny because
sometimes
i'll just have random bursts where i'm
like oh my god i just won the us open
but then i'd
just go about normal and realize
nothing's happened and these bursts will
just come and go so it's a strange
feeling to comprehend but um how
watching the match last night helped
really let it sink in yeah and and going
back to your training at the lta it's
going to be a bit different you know you
are the british number one you're the
world number 23 you are a grand slam
champion people are going to treat you
differently you can't just go in and
train anonymously are you prepared for
that
honestly i can't even get a call at my
local club like it's still
but uh i haven't really even thought of
that when i when i go back to training
um i'll see if anything changes but
until then nothing
and you know more demands on your time
obviously
now you're a superstar are you prepared
for that
yeah i think it i won't over commit
myself i'll just uh
take it take it how it is and you know i
think the most important thing for me is
still my tennis and improving and
training so i i won't let any commitment
get in the way of that because it's my
top priority
but what now though you've achieved your
goal which is to win a grand slam at
your second attempt at the age of 18.
some people would say that's it that's
the pinnacle
my my goal now is just to keep improving
and maximize my potential and what i can
do it's pretty amazing because i feel
like even though i won the u.s open
there are still many many aspects of my
game that i feel could improve and get
better so
i'll probably after some time off
reflect on what's just happened and then
go and go about and see where i can
improve and start working on those and
you had so much support from all around
the world from
so many famous people did any of the
messages make you particularly
starstruck
i
haven't really read all my messages till
i'm just trying to
enjoy the moment and coming home i
wanted to just spend time with my family
and in new york it was a really busy but
amazing experience so over the next few
days i'm hoping to to really plow
through some of them and i'm sorry if i
haven't replied yet
but you got a congrats from the queen
didn't you
yeah i did i received a note from her
majesty and it meant a lot that
she would she was following
the matches and
um i'm just really honored and grateful
and i'll probably cherish that letter
forever yeah maybe frame it um was there
anything finally that you were really
looking forward to when when you came
home something you were looking forward
to doing sleeping your own bed or eating
something particular and whatever it was
have you done it
yeah i think sleeping in my own bed uh i
woke up this morning and i didn't know
where i was it was one of those like
where am i but i also
had a really nice meal homemade
dumplings by my mom i was craving them
so
getting a taste of home was very very
nice so i've done that